this is one of the hardest obstacle
courses in all of minecraft there's a
lava tidal wave
endless cobwebs whatever the heck this
is and whichever one of these people
finishes it
first gets ten thousand dollars worth of
doritos
not even joking why doritos they taste
good
there they go they are off to the races
and now you might be wondering who is
this gentleman on your screen right here
his name's wilbur
this is his channel he has a really cool
voice oh he think i have a cool voice mr
beast the first course is this lava
thing of death the second course that we
need to talk about
is what do you even call this they're
stuck in the endless cobwebs
their only choice is to walk all the way
to the end look at this guy
he's gonna be stuck here forever he's
just always made this choice he's going
to go back and start again
here i'll add him to the call yeah hello
hey what's up
you're stuck in the cobweb yeah oh this
is insane
i just want to let you know gravy that
if you're the first to finish you get
10 000 worth of doritos i'm gonna be fed
for life thank you no prob
okay um oh oh my god that wasn't
happening before
oh wait those explode what you wanna
help me build a secret tunnel for them
yeah let's do it i think they're gonna
notice seeing us how they're all
right here watching all right let's see
here they come all right the floyd gates
have opened
wait what what is happening wait do they
have to ride that across we'll never
thought what's this guy doing look this
guy's figured it out what is this guy
doing
oh wait no it's invisible oh it's kind
of like uh fall guys where you like oh
when i said this is one of the hardest
obstacle courses ever i meant it
i don't even understand it oh spiderman
died look at these little things
they're riding on those are quick oh
oh dead oh another
this is a mean course so those reveal
where the path is and then the other
people have to walk across the path no i
think they're supposed to use riders
some people are just cheating
sounds like we need to use the snowballs
actually to move
you see this gate here will i refuse to
drop this gate until you murder someone
whoever you kill you're probably going
to ruin their chance at ten thousand
dollars worth of doritos you're giving
me so much power jimmy i'm not good
under this amount of pressure
drop the gate server now that will is a
murderer what's special about this part
of the course
is the lava is like following them oh
that guy could live up to it well i have
an important question for you good one
if i play one of your songs will you
claim me yes
if i do this first try can i have
permission to use the song you can have
one word of my
song if you okay i want it
i know all right belle even made it past
the first three blocks
that's fine i didn't want to play your
song mr beast i'm i'm hankering again i
need to kill again mr beast
you can kill all you want i'm not
allowed to kill people anymore i got
banished to the toilet last time
it's hungry i could do one worse chris
if i can get you out of the bad list of
people please dude i actually would love
that
get this guy in the vc i want to hear
him as i kill him
i got him i want to ask how do you feel
about this i can't really do anything
yes flaming how did that make you feel
sad
oh i've done a bad i feel bad are you
happy will
you should feel really bad you had to
listen to his voice i've never even done
that before
getting back i want to bring him back up
sorry we can't do you like doritos
flaming now do you like doritos
oh perfect okay that's good that was the
prize
oh well poor guy he literally fell in
the first one
oh look at this it's like popcorn
[Music]
wilbur just so you know if they fall
they go all the way back to the
beginning oh god
so that's where flaming gnaw went yeah
all the way to the beginning there's a
fate worse than death
once if i destroy the last block after
they um oh
no wilbur's so evil i'm gonna add these
people in i want to get their opinion on
the doritos
okay everyone i just added to the call
do you guys know what you're competing
for yet
nope whoever finishes first gets 10 000
oh in doritos that guy got set no don't
walk up
anyone else no one has any uh opinion on
that
what they don't want doritos you can get
it whatever flavor you want i didn't say
they had to be normal
he left the server and left the chat all
right oh god this guy's just speeding
through
what is he even standing on okay so
honey blocks uh
count as uh only 7 8 of a block nerd
these two people are trying to figure
out who should go first
hello there hey what's up why aren't you
guys going what are you trying to do
i don't know how to do a honey block
part four but just watch just watch me
i'll show you ready ready ready
boom that's two jumps ready boom that
honestly you did better than i thought
you would i think we have our first our
first one through it's poland
all right so let's add poland hello mr
beast this is a very important question
answer carefully do you actually live in
poland uh no
i do not live in poland all right get
out of here they're a fraud
you're a fraud you're a rod
oh no don't do it don't do it no
no no
why are so many people dying now that
wilbur's here we drove a man insane
where the heck is everyone what are
people struggling on maybe our fans just
aren't as good as they used to be
oh this is the bottleneck okay here
let's just do this there you go they
were literally just waiting
it looks like we're actually getting a
crowd catching up now could you like
sing us a song or something while
they're going through these honeycombs
[Music]
get better at honey block jumps
or i'm gonna kill you with snowballs
oh is this why we brought him off what
the heck is this glass doing here
wait there's no chance these kids are
gonna make this oh no
these are hard jumps as well like oh oh
poland's better get rid of this glass as
well yeah
go poland we are now approaching the
hardest part of the entire map
okay so these blocks are visible for a
few seconds
but a lava tide away follows them
and they have to make the jumps before
the tidal wave catches up to them
this is literally as hard as minecraft
gets this is too much stress for a 12
year old there's no way they can handle
this
oh he's gone what oh what would you do
lava wave following you
ten thousand dollars worth of doritos on
the line whoever wins
could eat like doritos every day till
the day they die that sounds like a life
i want to live
oh my gosh wait this is the end right
here and there's people waiting
at this checkpoint is somebody about to
get 10 000 doritos when we drop this
gate they literally just have to go from
here
to there the first one to touch the
diamond wins doritos i need you to sing
a song while they attempt this final
course
okay server drop the gate wilbur give
them a song while they go
[Music]
this is intense it is i love it
the music's complimenting it do you want
doritos
yeah yeah he died
mr beast will give you only you
doritos the rest of you have failed
you're too slow and you suck
hello what is up tension ask him if he
likes dorizos
before i tell you what you want do you
like doritos by any chance
yeah well congratulations cause you just
won
ten thousand dollars worth of doritos
yeah
i know you're over the moon you just won
the lottery practically
and i know what you're thinking what
kind of doritos well it's whatever kind
you want you want a thousand dollars of
every kind
it's up to you you can have it whoa dude
honestly man we're gonna have to just
end the video here i don't know if we
can handle this excitement thank you for
watching subscribe